hey guys Pete here it's going to be a
follow up to my season 7 episode 5
trailer breakdown for Game of Thrones
now look at what we've seen as far as
new photos from HBO this week and look a
little closer at some of the things that
we talked about in the comments from the
trailer breakdown if you're not caught
up through Game of Thrones season 7
episode 4 then there will be spoilers in
this video and you're going to want to
go watch something else
so the first new photo we got from HBO
is Tyrion walking across the field after
the battle one of the big topics of
conversation this week has been the fate
of his brother Jaime while most people
don't believe he's dead it is a big
question mark as to what's going to
happen to him once they fished him out
of the water just like I don't think
he's going to drown I don't think that
he got pulled right out right away where
Daenerys could just kill him so the most
likely theories are that he will escape
and head back to King's Landing or he
will come out of the water and he'll
become prisoner he is noticeably left
out of the trailer and these photos but
I think the fact that we see Tyrion
walking across the field is a good
indication that he's going to come in
contact with Jaime so the big question
isn't is he going to meet Jaime
it's whether he's going to meet him
before he gets away or will he meet him
as a prisoner later on down the road I'm
not really sure which way I lean on this
and it leads to a lot of speculation and
we really don't know the answer to and
we won't until it happens I mean
personally I don't think that Jaime will
remain a prisoner throughout the rest of
the season but that could mean that he
becomes a prisoner and then Tyrion
betrays Dany and lets him go after all
he kind of owes that to Jaime Jaime
defied both Cersei and Tywin by letting
him go and that led directly to Tywin's
death at Tyrion tan I do think that
Tyrion and Jaime have an unbreakable
bond not just for this but you know for
lots of things that have happened in
their past so if he meets him
face-to-face on the field somehow before
he's been captured I would imagine that
Tyrion would let him go and if he
becomes a prisoner if push comes to
shove I can see him letting them go as
well so try
men down below here to let me know what
you guys think but I just don't really
see Jamie being held hostage for any
significant period of time and I don't
see Tyrion going along with much in the
way of anything besides bargaining and I
just don't see Cersei going for it if
they were to say hey we'll trade you
Jaime for something else you know what I
mean like what's the trade like leave
King's Landing and we'll give you Jaime
back she's not going to go for that so
this is something that is going to
develop and I think it will develop
quickly but I just don't know for sure
how it's going to play out the next
photos from the trailer more or less
it's a photo of Dany and Tyrion looking
on at the soldiers of the defeated
Lannister army not much new to talk
about here and we talked about this
before the one thing I want to clear up
though is I was talking about in the
trailer breakdown how her tone with
these soldiers was different like the
people who followed her to Westeros
fought her because they wanted to she
was her their liberator you know she was
a liberating force and some people got
that mixed up and commented that why
would these guys think of her that way I
wasn't saying that or that you know
she's gone completely mad Queen or
anything either I'm just saying that her
conquest of Westeros is much different
than what we saw in Essos it's a brand
new situation things might not be great
under the Lannisters and Cersei did blow
up the steps but outside of that there
hasn't been anything major going on
politically to have these people where
they all want to get out of this crazy
Lannister rule you know what I'm saying
so that's all the student was comparing
those two things our role here is
different and there's a lot of history
here because the Mad King is still fresh
in people's memory it's not so long ago
that people forget we have two episode
five photos that involve theirs in the
first we see him sitting at the map
table in the Dragonstone Map Room I
would assume that this is connected to
Jon talking about the night King moving
towards East Watch since the episode is
titled east watch and that's the only
thing from the trailer where we saw that
was related to the Map Room and Varys
was in that shot the next one is him and
Tyrion sitting there drinking some wine
also probably just a different angle
a shot in the trailer this was one that
a lot of people talked about in the
comments in my video because they're
assisted Tyrion you have to find a way
to make her listen initially I said that
I thought this was about Daenerys but a
lot of people seem to think that he
might be talking about Cersei and
frankly this is a complete rabbit hole
here in my mind I can't think of any
reason why
Tyrion would be a good candidate to
parley with Cersei I mean she wants him
dead matter-of-factly no question about
it she just wants him dead even if we
knew everything to talk about Maggie the
Frog and everything else that kind of
has driven her life to this point the
chances of her listening to or just not
killing Varys or Tyrion on sight are
very low now of course there's different
things that could happen that would
change the dynamic but none of those
things have happened yet so I still kind
of stand by the idea that I think he is
talking about the nurse here but i could
be wrong i could be wrong anytime if he
is talking about Cersei let's just hope
that there's some kind of explanation of
how they expect that they'd be able to
have a actual conversation with Cersei
that doesn't end in the mountains
smashing someone's head against the wall
if this is after Jaime has been a
prisoner I can kind of buy into it but
still there's a lot of stuff that has to
happen in order for that talk to go down
speaking of surfacing the next shot is
her on a bed and it looks like she's
deep in thought about something could be
that the gold has arrived and that she
found out that they got destroyed on the
field after that could be that she got
word that Jamie's been captured could be
a lot of things when I first saw this I
did think about the fact that they had
that scene after she did the whole
dungeon atrocity was the sand snakes and
the fact that she went to Jaime and had
sex with him right after that like a
team like a really weird combination of
scenes they're like and I kind of joked
about it in the recap that you know it's
kind of showing that it turned her on
that she was doing that but there could
be something else and that could tie
back into the fact that in the earlier
episode where her and Jamie are talking
he says you know all of our kids are
dead what do we need to have a dynasty
for so since we don't really know how
long things are in between and all that
kind of stuff when I first saw it I
thought maybe this was her
are experiencing pregnancy but I don't
know that there's anything great to back
that up then we got our two pictures of
John and one he looks like he's
approaching the field I don't know if
he's approaching Daenerys or if he's
approaching where she's landing based on
the trailer to me it looks like he's
walking up to her to have the
conversation that we see in the second
photo they're having a heart-to-heart it
looks a little bit heated and I made a
whole video about how this is probably
another sign that they're going to end
up together before the end of the season
should check that out if you haven't
seen it turns out people have a lot of
feelings about that but I think it's
most likely that this is more him
telling her he needs to get out of
Dragonstone he's got his dragon glass
and he needs to go but I don't know is
if is that before they get to Raven from
bran and we see that where they're
talking about Eastwatch or if it's
before that and he leaves and then comes
back you know it's hard to say for sure
but John has been a dragon stone for a
very long time at this point so I'd say
it's safe to say he's ready to get
moving because he knows that the White
Walkers are moving and whether this is
before the Raven comes or not that will
just be the part that says ok this needs
to happen right now the final photo is
of Sam and Gilly at the Citadel they're
looking through literature which you
can't really tell what's there it looks
like Sam is transcribing those Scrolls
like he was supposed to and they're
having a conversation either about
something the Gilly found or they're
just discussing something else that Sam
came across I'm guessing this is pretty
predictably he's going to find out that
information that he needs to make him
leave the Citadel because I don't see
what the point of them being there
anymore would be the popular theories
here about what he's going to find are
that he's going to find out something
that's essential to defeating the White
Walkers and that's going to send him to
Winterfell to talk to brand because he's
going to know that brand has some
serious abilities to see what's going on
north of the wall or that he's going to
find out something about Rhaegar and
Lyanna most likely that they were
married before Jon Snow was conceived or
at the very least that he's going to
find out something about his parentage
which it makes a lot of sense I don't
know why he would go to Winterfell from
there but
either way he's going to find something
here that's going to make him leave the
Citadel before too long so if this photo
is an indication of that I wouldn't be
surprised but it's really kind of hard
to tell because we can't see what
they're looking at in the books so other
stuff that came up this week over the
last episode quite a few of you guys
asked me in the comments if I thought
that
Tyburn might have poisoned the bolts in
the scorpion okay I get there dark very
thing that you could see Qyburn doing
especially since we got the
foreshadowing of poison in the Elia and
taim scene but if it is if he is
poisoned I just don't see drugs on dying
no matter what like it would be really a
big surprise to me if the dragon dies I
mean think about how the story is gone
her hatching these dragons is the thing
that's bringing magic back into the
world and they can't just start dying
all of a sudden I mean they're important
because they're supposed to go up
against the White Walkers right so yeah
that could be a thing that he could be
poison but I just don't think that the
dragons going to die another thing I've
been seeing around a lot too is this
idea that that Tyrians betrayal will be
that betrayal for love and I know that
they didn't actually bring this out in
the show but it is part of the overall
story and yeah I think there's a good
chance like I said earlier I think that
there's a pretty good chance that he
will if he's put in that position he
will let Jamie go I mean he sort of has
to another reason beyond what I said
earlier I just don't see Cersei ever
making a deal to get Jaime back
so if you have an idea of what they
could offer as a deal for her to trade
something for Jaime let me know in the
comments because I just can't really
come up with one they did foreshadow the
golden company and I you know I've read
some theories saying that that's going
to be what tips the scales in order for
her to beat Daenerys I don't think
that's going to happen I think I just
sort of even things up again to draw but
I'll be interested to read what you guys
think too another thing that a lot of
people are talking about this point is
gendry's return I think that is likely I
don't want to get into flat out filming
spoilers here because everything that
came from that is speculation anyway
but we do know Joe Dempsie who played
Gendry attended the LA premiere we know
he was in Spain and he shot scenes and
if we look at everything else as far as
what we expect to happen I think it
makes the most sense for him to come out
here many people have said that John
needs a blacksmith for all this
dragonglass that he's mining that could
be a way that it brings Gentry back into
the story they were looking for one they
find him
other people have brought up the fact
that Melisandre left for volantis but I
know I read an article with Chris Van
Houten and she said that she has no more
scenes in episodes even 7 so I think
that's less likely her role will come
back out in season 8 as far as other
stuff that we haven't seen in all
Armand's I would like to see The Hound
arrive at least watch he had that vision
so we can imagine that's where he's
headed with the rest of the Brotherhood
without banners I'd like to see that
happen I made a video about him and rule
or a couple weeks back and I'm very
curious to see how that storyline is
going to play out I mean we do know for
sure that he's going to make it beyond
the wall from trailers and things so
that would be nice to see him get there
at this episode but other than that I
think that's about it let me know what
you guys are excited about after you
thought about it for a week
we're almost there please like the video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already what do
you think is going to happen up in
Winterfell this episode let me know
about that in the comments do you think
anything major is going to happen at
King's Landing with Cersei make sure you
follow me on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram you can interact with me over
there thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon